this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app all of us
babies use the cash app which is why is
the number one finance app in the App
Store and now the cash cart is more
powerful than ever with cash apps latest
feature cash boost download the cash app
get your free cash card and select your
boost save money when you swipe on stuff
like coffee
Chipotle Shake Shack and more download
the free cash app for iOS or Android now
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't know why but when I was talking
into the microphone and breathe then I
breathed in [ __ ] hair and there was a
hair on my microphone now the weirdest
thing is it was a [ __ ] coarse blonde
dog hair I guess it could have been some
salmon butters but that's very weird
you guys it's episode 77 download my app
in the App Store crystal either type
that into the App Store and you can go
along with us live right now it's the
only way to listen to my podcast and
watch my podcast live some people are on
there right now saying what's up and I'm
looking at him and I'm comment and
somebody writes what's wrong dad I don't
know why I don't know there uh I was
going to bed but babies don't sleep and
they put a space in between SL and EEP
that's very very very very very South
American to make that kind of a mistake
anyway what's up so we're sitting here
it's episode 77 and I'm gonna be in
Houston let's get that out of the way
I'm gonna be in Houston Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday
Yanis Tammy I want to be in [ __ ]
Houston sliven it up dude I love Houston
and I know it's going to be a hundred
and seventy-five degrees there and I
know it's going to be humid as [ __ ] to
make it feel like 210
and I know I'm going to see cowboy hats
and I know I'm going to see cowboy boots
and I know that that's going to make me
upset but I love Houston and I'm gonna
perform there it's probably sold out I'm
not sure but there are maybe a few
tickets left so go you know I don't
think it's sold out yet there's probably
some some some tickets available on
certain nights but uh so yeah I I was
getting my coffee earlier I have my spot
and how cool looks like man how annoying
is it when you get like a little bit of
a buggy up in the top of your [ __ ]
nose and you and you're still doing it
like that and if it sounds like you're
on coke and now and and then people are
like you know what I always like I have
such a [ __ ] thing about how people
cuz I I know people think I do coke and
[ __ ] when they see me on stage and do
all the [ __ ] because I'm very like
animated and stuff I don't do drugs but
I'm always a conscious of that so
anytime I like wipe my nose or have to
sniff I'm like oh great people gonna
think I do coke even more now so I was I
was getting my coffee and the [ __ ]
guy and the guy was trying to TMZ me and
I was just like it was like hey man
what's up I was like oh what's going on
in the coffee shop and he was like you
mind if I get if I interview you
afterwards and I was like oh I don't
know man I'm like I'm like [ __ ] tired
of [ __ ] but we'll see and I left the
place and I pretended like I was on the
phone I hate doing that
I hate pretending like I'm on the phone
because it makes me feel like a [ __ ]
but it's better to just of I don't want
to do that I want to because I want to
be a guy that's just like and I am I'm
I'm I'm Way more like this than anybody
I know I say to people know you know and
I look in their eyes and I make them
feel that but like sometimes I just
don't want to have to use that energy
and I just want to like I'll be like
I'll just put them on the phone
it's a [ __ ] move dude we're all [ __ ]
I'm a [ __ ] a little bit right but it's
okay at least one fart is gross like Ace
Ventura right now
he's got a [ __ ] Hawaiian shirt on so
that's cool and but
yeah so I did that and I got out of it I
don't know I don't mind doing
TMZ stuff sometimes if I'm like filling
it but like dude this guy hit my car the
other day like it wasn't a bad a bad
thing it not no no cuts showed up on my
car but he was like he got out and TMZ
got out this other TMZ guy was like hey
man
and I was like he was with his camera
and I was like hey man like I just got
out of my car because somebody hit me
and he was like what's up dude and I was
like I just got into an accident man and
he was like oh and he wasn't filming me
but he was like you want to like make it
funny or something and I said oh no you
know hey do you want to make it funny
ahead also it's not you're not helping
me
you know TMZ needs content I don't I I I
don't know I I don't really watch TMZ
and I mean I've seen it when I'm on it
and all that [ __ ] is Akaka but um you
know don't come up to a guy when you
unless you're trying to just film the
accident and it's like a high krisily I
got in an accident dolling by like I
want to do a [ __ ] interview what the
heck Chris D'Elia got in an accident
uh-oh what does that mean for season
three of Whitney why do they have that
guy you know what the heck we caught up
with Tracy Morgan and he had a parrot
outside of what's that [ __ ]
restaurant
what's that restaurant for [ __ ] sake
dude I can never remember the [ __ ]
thing I want to remember dude I'm going
my memory is I'm 38 my memories it's
just gonna go dude what's the [ __ ]
catch that's the [ __ ] goddamn
restaurant it's one warden it's so easy
to find we caught up with Tracy Morgan
and he had a parrot at catch would have
been so much funnier if I just said it
when I [ __ ] said it dude but I didn't
set it and for
get it you ever see that [ __ ]
infomercial with the [ __ ] guy
dude that guy jizz is so much you know
what that guy dude
set it and forget it and then it burns
set it and forget it and it burns nope
you got to remember you got to ended up
taking it out of the [ __ ] goddamn
oven otherwise your house burns down
that's how it should be set it and
forget it until you got to remember and
you take it out of the oven otherwise
your house burns down that should be the
[ __ ] whole thing then alright dude
isn't it it's by Ronco hey that's the
most dude just made up
six lobster tails and they taste amazing
this guy looks like a Duracell battery
guy remember those guys were the [ __ ]
Duracell battery in the backs dude
imagine getting a Ronco rotisserie
[ __ ] twister or whatever the [ __ ] it
is Ronco Showtime rotisserie and
barbecue compact model put the beans and
and the and [ __ ] carrots in there and
the rotisserie set it and forget it then
take it out eat it and it tastes dry as
[ __ ] and they always have to eat it and
they're like wow okay Wow okay Wow
that's what the [ __ ] girl always does
she'll eat it and she'll be like okay
okay Wow shut up dude it sucks I want to
do one of those and I want to get it I
want to set it and forget it and then
they always have it [ __ ] now we
already made one and they have it they
have it like and it's just in there and
you just wait twenty five minutes and
it'll be golden and then they always
have one that's already done and they
pull it out and they taste it and she
eats it and she goes wow not in it not
in it not in it iiiiii I don't know you
know no [ __ ] no but Ronco that
[ __ ] name Ronco Ronco sounds like the
[ __ ] fourth best soccer player isn't
there a guy named something like that
Ronco Ronco scores wrong go
oh dribbles it down the card and drunk
courts a basketball field anyway yeah
set it and forget it
so I and I was I [ __ ] this guy came up
to me the other day when I was sitting
having my [ __ ] coffee dude I'm an old
lady I don't give a [ __ ] man I'm an old
lady I said I have coffee and I [ __ ]
sit with my friend sometimes I sit alone
and I do my [ __ ] it's like I might as
well be doing a crossword but this
[ __ ] guy came up to me he was like
hey man is this seat taken and I was
like oh dude there's an open seat over
there and I pointed over there he looked
like [ __ ] tee I kinda and he was like
yeah but uh he's like god I just want to
ask you a few questions I was like oh
man what's going on what didn't want to
you know should have read the signs and
he says I was just like wondering you
know cuz I want to be a comedian I'm
like I'm a comedian he said I said I'm a
comedian and I wanted to you know just
pick your brain a little bit and like
you know first of all no you know second
of all there's no second of all first of
all no second of all there's no second
of all but he was like you know I'm a
comedian and I wanted to I wanted to you
know I moved out here a few months ago
and I just wanted to let you know I
wanted to get get out here and like you
know my uncle was like man you got to do
the open mikes and you got to like get
good that way but like I'm not about all
that you know I'm like I already got
some stuff but like I'm just trying to
like skip all that and I was like yeah
you can't do that and he was like yeah
but like I mean like you know like I
know like that's not cool to say but
like I could do it he's like I just got
to get up there and I was like well have
you ever done stand-up and he said nah I
said oh so you're not a comedian and he
said well no I mean I you know like if I
just get up there I'll figure it out
after a few times and I was like hey man
he was like guys is there any way like I
could get your contact info and I was
like nah I'm not gonna give you my
number and he was like what about your
manager and I said hey man you're not
gonna do anything with this info you're
not gonna [ __ ] get in touch with my
manager you're just talking [ __ ] so
okay my manager is at three arts go [ __ ]
an email
like a high alright man alright he
[ __ ] had this whole conversation with
me wasted my time like he's not gonna do
it he's not gonna [ __ ] do it people
love talking about what the you know how
I know he's not gonna do it cuz he's
[ __ ] coming up to me and asking me for
tips that's why I know he's not gonna
[ __ ] do it
I didn't ask anybody for tips I just
[ __ ] went up there and I did it that's
how you be a comedian um you don't have
to [ __ ] ask anybody for tip there's
no tips there's no shortcuts you just go
you set it and forget it dude you get on
stage and you set it and you forget it
dude how about in Houston Texas it's a
hundred degrees move it's a hundred
[ __ ] degrees right now in Houston
Texas move precipitation 10% move
humidity off the charts move set it and
forget it like it's like how many I
don't know but it was it's so it's so
weird how people just want to waste your
time because they want to feel good
about themselves
hi I mean I always go back to this but
like the people who write like their
long Instagram captions I I think
actually nobody reads those like not
even 3% like if you're the rock okay but
if you're just some guy with like a New
York fitted hat on and abs and you're
like hey the second you get into your
third or fourth sentence hey see ya get
gum dude you're not no you're doing it
free that's Jason you're Jason on social
media you're going on ma that's what
you're doing nobody wants that on them
you aren't cheers on you know you don't
want Jays anja you want unsolicited jizz
onion no so you're not reading it you're
not reading it unless you want
unsolicited jizz on you the only
reason why anybody would read any of
those captions all the way through is if
you actually wanted to be in a subway or
in a car and [ __ ] it or in a in a Kinkos
or a Costco and somebody to come up to
you and spray some unsolicited jizz on
you that's exactly what it is you want
some unsolicited jizz on you know and I
know people are like you know some
people might listen to what I just said
and be like well that makes no sense
well you guys aren't invited to my log
cabin dude and I swear to god man I'm
making sense here I'm making [ __ ]
sense if you read those long Instagram
captions from a guy with a New York
fitted hat on and abs then you want
unsolicited jizz on you you want more
you are the kind of guy who wants
unsolicited jizz on them more than a
regular person I'll tell you that much
it's what it is man
it's what it is dark it's what it is how
about when a guy can't well how about
dude this guy hit on me at my gym and
and I was in the locker room and he was
like hey man would you workout today and
I was like I worked out my shoulders and
my back and he was like ah cool man it's
so tiring I was like yeah and I [ __ ]
I wasn't really looking at him and then
I caught at the corner of his eye I
don't have a quarter of my height his
dong was in full view he was completely
naked ape dude his [ __ ] pigeon was
out you know and he had so much so many
pubes - it looked like his dick was
hiding he looked like his dick was in
Vietnam you ever have [ __ ] you ever
see somebody with such fierce pubes that
it looks like his dick was in Vietnam
[Laughter]
you ever I can see a guy whose [ __ ]
dude if your pubes are longer than your
[ __ ] dick what
those aren't pubes those are banana
leaves dude you're in Vietnam you're in
Nam
dude any time I see a guy whose pubes
are longer than his [ __ ] dick I want
to be like oh dude you're in Nam uh
anyway he was like so so in this guy's
dick was so in Vietnam dude he was like
he was like hey man
so would you work out and I was like
shoulders him back and he was like and
that was when I noticed the dick was in
Vietnam and I was like oh [ __ ] and like
and I was like god Cooley's I got so so
it was like we got a busy weekend or oh
that's what he said and I was like yeah
I'm just working you know I don't want
to be like I have shows because then
he'd be like what are you a magician can
you make my dick appear more and then I
was like yeah so I just I was working
he's like ah that's cool well whatever
you know no I was like whew it's hard to
not ask the question back I was like
what do you got going on which basically
means hey I want to [ __ ] suck your
[ __ ] in the locker room can't-can't
online and so um I wanna [ __ ] kick in
the lancome game and them is the
convenient man is it [ __ ] vietnam
because the fans could see a bomb I
could see you dick Bahamut Vietnam me
get banana leaf and only pain on the
pant pant pant leaf uh so he's like he's
like I was like so what do you got going
on he's like I think I'm gonna do a hike
later at Griffith it's like very like it
I was like oh yeah here's I extra
[ __ ] awesome over there basically
just [ __ ] I might as well just bent
over I'm having a full-on conversation
with this guy and but whatever I don't
give a [ __ ] who cares
and then and then I was like yeah you
wanna I was like yay I was like you
wanna go get a drink I was like so uh so
uh that's cool I hear those hikes are
nice and you I mean I'm Jesus Christ I'm
[ __ ] hitting back on this guy and
this guy's like yeah cool and then and
then I was like ah I see you bro that's
it I got out there without getting
[ __ ] or putting a [ __ ] in my mouth and
anyway so but I was I was one time I was
in the that locker room and I was with
my Irish buddy if I got a guest past
four guests past four and this other guy
was in the locker room and we started
all talking and [ __ ] that's cool how
much mucus I have today and and he says
and he says the guy says something about
are you guys brothers because we look
alike I guess to idiots because we don't
really look alike it's just we both have
long hair and he says and my [ __ ] got
my virus buddy mark is like oh yeah but
I'm better looking huh and I'm like okay
we're in a gym in West Hollywood don't
say that and then a guy and the guy goes
like this and the guy goes like this uh
how about guys who do this this is this
is the best this is this is sick this is
actually the most closeted gay thing you
can do he says oh man I can't tell if a
guy's attractive or not man he's like I
just I don't know if a guy's
good-looking or not you guys say that
like guys say there are guys that are
like I can't tell if our guys
good-looking or not what you got eyes
right that's the most closeted thing you
can say I think you know cuz it's like
you know you oh you got eyes can you
tell if a car looks nice or not is it
got dents in it and as it got paint
chipping sugg lee does the guy have a
big bulbous nose and does you sweat a
lot and is he balding sug
does he have [ __ ] abs and blue eyes
of Steel and the [ __ ] jaw line and a
[ __ ] full head of hair and is he 29
good-looking doesn't mean you gotta [ __ ]
him it's so weird that people are like
he's like I can only tell if chicks a
good-looking man like oh yeah really
cool man oh cool dude you're the man hey
dude you're the man and then after we
got out of the the the the locker room I
was like hey man that was cool how you
were trying to [ __ ] that guy and he said
oh what are you talking about and I said
oh well you asked him who was
better-looking me are you in the locker
room that's [ __ ] in a gym in West
Hollywood he's like oh I didn't even
realize it
oh yeah that's what makes you [ __ ]
dumb hey drive by ah ah hey dude come on
and but that's that was so that was it's
a lot of gay [ __ ] going on in that
locker room mm-hmm
but I you know I you know listen
whenever I haven't noticed much Thank
You pinky in that locker room though I
just I I think like what's crazy is like
you know what I saw that Sacha Baron
Cohen thing like which is [ __ ]
amazing
of course that guy's just great and who
is America hmm and the guy on it
the-the-the lib really liberal who
apologizes for being a cisgender white
male the character he plays goes and has
dinner with these Republican this
Republican couple and the guy is
obviously gay and but you know he
doesn't know it or doesn't admit it or
whatever the [ __ ] you know and I was
thinking about guys who like are
closeted and [ __ ] and like or guys who
know they're gay but are like hiding
from it or guys you don't know there's
people who don't know they're gay
there's guys who don't know
gay that are gay and look that's a real
shame that sucks because you know it's
all you know the society we live in is
still unaccepting to it to us you know
not non [ __ ] WeHo but like you know
you go to Nebraska or [ __ ] wherever
people are like no it's better that's
not that's not how it is you know it's
not how God intended it to be you don't
put another you don't put a dick in a
man's butt and cuming it you do not do
that
that's for exit that's for exiting okay
so but the guy was obviously gay you
know just because of how he was gay he
was being you know he was like I do the
laundry and most of the time because I
like doing them the you know the
traditionally females housework and
anyway but he was married to this girl
but I was thinking about how like there
are definitely some guys that are hmm
like there's there's there are the guys
that are like look I'm gay I don't want
anybody to know I'm gonna get married
and have kids I don't need that [ __ ]
drama in my life where people are like
attacking me and [ __ ] like that fine I
understand
but there are the guys too
that convince themselves that they are
not gay even though they are gay which
is another level of it which is wild to
me because you know there's there's
definitely those guys out there that are
like I am married and I am with a girl
that I don't really find that attractive
but I wanted to have a family she's not
a model couldn't get a model models are
beautiful you know but like you know if
you're a guy and you've been with a girl
that is very pretty but you're not like
sexually charged buyer like I've been in
those situations where I've I've been
with I've dated girls where are there
are beautiful but I didn't want to rip
their clothes off but in my head I'm
like you know what
that's not the most important thing
right the most important thing is you
you know it's not necessarily sex which
now I actually I've come out on the
other side of I think that sex is
arguably the most important thing in a
relationship but you know among other
things but I you know you think of oh
how you know you hear people say well
you got to marry your best friend which
is a bunch of horseshit I think you know
that drives me nuts when people all like
I get to marry my best friend or like I
murdered my best friend Oh God
cool work for hallmark Sega right right
some [ __ ] cards with some blurry
candle pics and then of golden writing
over it and so so it's like a level of
that where it's like you know we've all
been with well maybe we not we have not
all been with but we've been with we
some of us have been with the girls that
well and you hear girls talk about all
the time like well he's like he checks
all the boxes he's really handsome but
you don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] him right
he's just like a provider or some [ __ ]
so guys do that too
hmm and I don't know cuz I've done that
I've dated girls that I didn't want to
like viscerally destroyed them in a
sexual way and so I think that there are
these guys that have that mindset that
are like oh I don't want to have I don't
want to tear these girls clothes off but
there are those Victoria's Secret models
say or swimsuit Illustrated swimsuit
Sports Illustrated models and those
women are very beautiful I'm never gonna
get those beautiful women but so I
settled with a my wife or whatever and
they look at those Sports Illustrated
swimsuit sports though swimsuit models
and they're like a beautiful girl but
they don't viscerally want to [ __ ] those
girls either so they but they and they
do want it like they do see guys and
they're like ooh I'd like to [ __ ] that
guy right but they they they bury that
into thinking like oh well that's all
guys are like that that's not gay that's
just like a thing guys or like and they
convince themselves that like
Oh guys are like that but the gay thing
would be to act on it right and there
are guys like that that just lie to
themselves and are in marriages and have
families and that think that it's not
gay to want to [ __ ] a guy and that's so
[ __ ] that sucks you know like to live
that lie sucks and it sucks that people
feel they don't even get to the point
where they're like oh I can't come out
of the closet you know and anyway my
whole point is that's who I think Mike
Pence is like that's my whole point if
because he's that's why he has all those
you know he that's why he's against
homosexuality and [ __ ] cuz he's like I
you know I gotta prove it to myself that
I'm not gay and that's it and I want you
to write that whole thing on my
tombstone I don't want to ruin it but
Marc Maron has a has the funniest
[ __ ] bit on Mike Pence right now it's
so [ __ ] funny so look here we go
mmm-me undies oh good I like talking
about me undies because it's a product I
care about you've heard me talk about
them before mm-hm
they're the you know the fun comfy
undies that feel as good as they look
I've got so many pair the that's all I
would wear to those of you who haven't
tried them yet listen up you can get
incredible underwear sent to your door
with me undies meaning no more hunting
around for the perfect pair at a crowded
store and eventually settling for good
enough me undies are made with
sustainably sourced material from beach
wood trees they're naturally soft fiber
makes a fabric that won't sag down or
ride up trust me once you put on a pair
you'll never want to take them off there
they are truly amazing and this is
crystal Lea who says it I like them
they're different they have regular
plain colors they have vibrant colors
they have just gray ones if you want
ones they have ones with avocados on
them they can they have ones that are
colorful they have ones for pride you
know for pride week they sent me ones I
wear them all I love them I work out in
them
I wear them from a lifestyle they're
great I'm telling you they're great if
you're not sure still okay well my
undies has a deal for my listeners
first-time purchasers get 20% off their
first pair of me undies and free
shipping that's 20% off plus free
shipping and a guarantee that you and
your me undies will be very happy
together
get your butt over to me undies calm and
treat yourself to get your 20% off your
first pair free shipping and a 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to my undies
comm / Congrats that's my undies comm /
Congrats mmm here's another product I I
think is very cool we all have great
photos on our phone birthdays
graduations weddings but what happens to
them most of us including me even the
best photos they never make it off of
our phones I've got 8000 phone photos in
my phone in my phone and let's be honest
some of those photos deserve more than a
Facebook post or any email it's true and
a lot of them just wind up staying in
your phone some photos should be where
you can see them every day
keepsake frames is the easiest way to
frame photos from your phone in seconds
whether you're doing some home
decorating or looking for a thoughtful
personal gift it's easy you download the
key keepsake frames app upload a photo
and choose a frame every keepsake frame
has a hand made in the USA from highly
quality materials they even have canvas
options okay
now through July 4th they are offering
an incredible deal for our listeners 30%
off your first order when you use promo
code Congrats download the keepsake
frames app and get 30% off plus free
shipping when you use promo code
Congrats that's 30% off with the
keepsake frames app promo code Congrats
so go check it out Square cash if you
haven't heard we're switching to the
cash app by now it's the number one
ranked app in the fight in
and lets you do the most with your money
whether you want to pay people back buy
and sell Bitcoin deposit your paycheck
right into the app or order a free
custom cash card to spend anywhere you
like now the cash card is more powerful
than ever with cash apps latest feature
cash boost the cash cards boost lets you
get instant discounts every time you
swipe your card right now you can get a
dollar off every purchase you make at
coffee shops across the country when you
pay with your cash card and you know
what it doesn't stop there I see
discounts like 15% off at Chipotle Shake
Shack and more they're rolling out new
booths for the cash cart constantly so
follow at Cash app on Twitter and catch
up on Instagram to find out what booths
are next to get boosted download the
cash app and get your free cash card and
select your boost and of course when you
download the cash up and enter rewards
code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund download the free cash app for iOS
or Android now had a lot of clap backs
this past week and you know what I did
this week that I that I did this week at
what do you call it as I went on a hike
and you know I always like to go into
the gym or like doing jujitsu or working
out on my house because it felt fun and
it was just I could get was efficient
you know what I'm talking about
but my buddy trying to get me going this
hike so I was like alright if we all go
we got five guys I said I'll go and we
went to a to do a hike and it was like
one of these 80 it was I get 90 degree
day I think was over that but I was like
[ __ ] it who gives a [ __ ] we'll do it and
I had my [ __ ] shorts on dude
I had my shirt on it's like I'll
probably take it off get some color do
the hike and we did this hike man we did
the easy run first there was like three
of them and then
my hope and her mic was like he was like
warning we're gonna do all three and I
was like we'll see you know so we did
the easy one and I was like let's just
do the hardest one and then that'll be
it so we did the easy one was tough I
ran it a lot I read almost the whole way
you know jog not [ __ ] sprinting or
anything and it's tough and then I did
the hard one which is like dude hiking
is very hard ok now I work out every day
or nearly every single day if I'm
traveling I can't or whatever so my body
was real sore and I was like I'm gonna
take a hike though because it's my off
day now it it was brutal this hike we
were we were I mean you almost had to
use your hands like it was like we were
we were like a rock climbing up this
[ __ ] mountain and [ __ ] and I was
sweating hard obviously but it was good
you know we were getting workout and I
was like I'll do leg day maybe in the
next day and there was no [ __ ] way I
was gonna be doing leg day the next day
your boy does leg day I know he's got
thin legs I workout legs more than I
workout [ __ ] anything I don't know
why it's happening why I still have
skinny legs but anyway we did this hike
and and I was thinking it I kept
thinking afterwards first of all no no
first of all I kept thinking afterwards
is how lazy and [ __ ] fat we are like
we're so lazy so fat we have cars where
we go everywhere and we don't even want
to end like I talked about the the I
mean dude I was in local Houma
fat [ __ ] everywhere and and these end
this and I've told you about the girl
that was like I don't want to walk to
the elevator dude this is how it was
hiking wasn't hiking thousands of years
ago
you know what hiking was walking hiking
was gay
to where you're going it wasn't a
[ __ ] exercise it wasn't a leisurely
activity it was the way there were no
cars you had to go get your food you had
to go hunt you had to go find your
[ __ ] food and you had to do it on
terrain there were no paved anything
there was no gradual incline there were
steps on rocks there were the [ __ ]
steps where you had to step up and then
put your hand on your knee and go ahead
and walk up and that was every step I
can't stop thinking about how it used to
be like that how much we don't do that
now and I'm an active person I'm a very
active person and this was hard for me
imagine I'm imagine how [ __ ] we don't
have to but this is how fat and how lazy
and how [ __ ] we are not only that
we're eating mostly bad food I mean we
had to go we had to eat sugar because
like you know from fruit by the way not
from [ __ ] Smarties and candy corns we
had to eat from fruit because we didn't
know when our next meal was going to
happen that's why we needed sugar
because it would pack on our [ __ ] fat
and then go find the [ __ ] we were going
to eat we didn't drive down to the
[ __ ] Gelson's and this was every day
imagine how fit everybody was and and
then you had to move if you wanted to
move oh you were taking everything
you were [ __ ] packing up and taking
everything dude we are [ __ ] and then
I'm like how the [ __ ] do we
how does our life expectancy get more
get higher and higher its we could have
because of the medicine I guess that's
gotta be why otherwise I mean that's
that's cool dude we're eating I I have
been eating the past seven days I ate no
sugar I ate the only cards I had were
brown rice every now and then
Oh like were [ __ ] plants and meat and
it felt good you know and yesterday I
ate it was my cheat day and I was like I
want to see if I eat whatever the [ __ ] I
want how I feel so I did I ate tacos
they weren't that bad they were just
like there were eggs in them and [ __ ]
and corn the corn tortilla [ __ ] shell
nutshell it wasn't it was just like the
soft one and then and then I had Chinese
food which is horrible for you and then
after a later night I had [ __ ] two
burgers and a milkshake and I was like
I'm gonna kill it I want to do this
because I want to see how I feel the
next day I want to woke up uh when I
feel awful
oh I woke up I I did the thing we're
like you know when you almost throw up
in your walk when you're walking you're
walking you feel nauseous I had to stop
that's how nauseous I was I got a stop
and concentrate everything on not
throwing up I can't well if I take
another step oh if I take another step
I'll blow chunks so so back to the
[ __ ] plant [ __ ] man and and a little
bit of meat and some brown rice because
the more I get older just I think about
how horrible it is what we [ __ ] eat
and I'm not telling anybody to [ __ ]
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want eat
whatever the [ __ ] you want but you gonna
get you know you can get cants eat
whatever you want don't be shocked when
you get cans
yeah it sucks I stopped drinking
coca-cola and any kind of sugar like
soda because I read an article once
years ago and it was about it was about
an article about coca-cola and they were
like yeah they were like trying to
figure out how to sell more coke and the
CEO or whatever the [ __ ] the guy in
charge I don't know if is the actual CEO
but he was like we need to it wasn't
they weren't like we need to figure out
how to sell more coke they literally
said we need to figure out how to get
more coke into people and I was like wow
that really was so disgusting to me that
I was like I got a not drink this [ __ ]
they don't want to say they aren't
looking at it like selling more product
they're looking at it like to get more
of the coke into the people gross
wheat containers it was so gross to me
I'd stop drinking I stopped drinking
coke there I started I was like maybe
I'll drink diet coke and I'll try to
[ __ ] diet coke Sox dude diet any soda
sucks people liked it better than
regular coke those people you can't try
you know what those people are
communists deep down I can't [ __ ]
believe somebody would rather drink a
diet soda than a soda that's so gross
it's so chemical and a taste chemical
and I sorts tried to do it because I
hear that people love it and I was like
dude this sucks I stopped drinking that
and I just ran club soda water and
coffee that's all I drink at a milkshake
yesterday but that's it um anyway this
is boring dude you're talking about a
high heat am I talking about hiking and
what I eat like I'm some [ __ ]
educational podcast [ __ ] that this is
the most educational podcast you can get
congratulations what else did I do this
week
when I thought I didn't but I was hiking
you know what else it was all you know
what else is weird about the hiking
thing like we were running a lot of us
we were there were five of us [ __ ]
[ __ ] I just my skin got caught on this
[ __ ] leather [ __ ] and it burned it so
we were running and I was like keeping a
steady pace and sometimes got the guys
would go faster than me
and then they'd stop running and then
I'd keep my steady pace and I'd get
ahead of them and then they'd run this
is what is weird being a guy if I am at
a steady pace and I'm catching up to
somebody this is how stupid I am I'm
like I gotta beat that guy or if I'm at
a steady pace and they're gaining on me
I'm like I gotta pick up my pace that's
my first thought okay now I think that
every guy kind of feels that way you got
to feel that this is for the girls I'm
telling girls right now how it is okay
cuz you're a girl you don't know what
it's like to think like a guy okay so
this is that so so I so like they get up
to like Craig well I was my buddy Craig
he was gaining on me and I was like I
can't let him beat me and then I'm like
and then I immediately think cuz I'm not
a [ __ ] idiot
I think wait hold on it literally
doesn't matter at all if I beat him or
not so just keep my steady pace but I
have to like control my thinking and
things just keep my studies pace I don't
need to be incan in this is like all
going on in my [ __ ] head I don't need
to beat him I don't need to prove
anything to anybody I'm literally just
jogging who gives a [ __ ] I'm doing this
for me and my health and I'm out here
having a good time
this is me thinking while I'm jogging
okay on a [ __ ] leisurely on a
recreational activity
alright this isn't the Olympics every
time I pass somebody or was passed one
of my buddies I think I got a [ __ ]
there the first thought was no no I
can't let him do it then I think not
enough [ __ ]
it's so dumb the dumbest [ __ ] thing
like why do I as a guy need to beat
Craig to the fence like what the [ __ ] is
it about a guy but that's what makes us
move society forward that's why we build
walls that's why we [ __ ] invent stuff
is that crazy that [ __ ] thought that
a guy has that that maybe girls who are
top athletes have but if that is not a
female thought I feel like like a male
thought of I can't let that guy beat me
I got to be better than that guy
like even me who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about that kind of stuff and I don't I I
have to think like okay dude calm down
you don't need to beat this guy to the
[ __ ] fence like a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
we're a [ __ ] to our thoughts we're
[ __ ] to our [ __ ] you know what do
you call that lineage but with like
[ __ ] what's the word whatever it is
evolution or whatever the [ __ ] I don't
know who cares you know what I'm talking
about right
Wow did you do that in my feelings
challenge I you know everything's a
challenge dude it's not a challenge
you're just dancing I wanted to do one
where I would I hear but I didn't know I
had I didn't I should have had [ __ ]
my producer make it but where I was like
in the car and the music started playing
and I was like alright here we go and
then I was like no you got to slow down
and they were doing it too fast and then
I step out and then it cuts to like
stock footage of a guy falling out of a
car and like maybe getting run over
while the music still is going Kiki do
you love me why does everyone love that
what is that about that I don't get it I
don't get why things and I'm not I like
it I like the song fine
what is it about that part that made
everyone go crazy so weird right
I don't like any challenges any of the
challenges I did the manic I did a joke
of the mannequin Channel challenge and
that was I thought I'm the best mountain
mannequin challenge black B does me a
Paul Marquart related that's not how it
goes I'm it's not how relation goes Kiki
do you love me
Drake is so good at doing those things
that people just want to [ __ ] say I'm
gonna do one I'm gonna do a Kiki
challenge so old the guy in my feelings
challenge I just don't I don't like how
people are like getting out of the car
and like doing it like I want somebody
to get hit is that bad I want somebody
to get [ __ ] I want somebody to you
know somebody out there's twisted their
ankles so [ __ ] hard in the [ __ ]
Kiki challenge and they're like oh oh I
would love to see that one that's my
favorite Kiki challenge sold you had to
call it Kiki challenge I don't know what
else to talk about we're on the phone
guys do you like that I forgot I was
doing a podcast and I'm just talking
right now it's actually uh I'm except
did you see that Sacha Baron Cohen thing
that was amazing dude I don't want to
ruin it but the characters that he does
are so [ __ ] good you know what makes
him so good this is the [ __ ] thing
that made me think about how like he's
so
better at this kind of [ __ ] than anybody
when he talks to that guy
well it's the whole beginning of the
whole gun commercial that they're trying
to do to sell guns to children or like
whatever to armed children and when the
guy says you want me to say on camera
like he's being incredulous he's like
you want me to say on you want me to see
I say on camera that I'm in support of
giving toddlers guns right and then and
then anybody at that moment that was
doing it would would come up with some
[ __ ] or this like long-winded like
thing where it's like well it's not
about that I'd like that you know
anybody was tricking trying to trick
somebody with and Sacha Baron Cohen just
says yes which is so good because it's
so what the character would do because
the character doesn't think that that's
wrong right
but everybody not everybody but a lot of
people who were trying to do that would
let their character slip and be like I
understand it sounds ridiculous or
whatever the [ __ ] but he's just like
well yes of course like that is what I
want because that's what's normal in
Israel right is what he's pretending it
was so [ __ ] funny that he just said
yes like that's so [ __ ] good he's the
best at that
that [ __ ] is unbelievable and you know
how people are like so I saw that [ __ ]
and obviously the Republicans got it the
worst you know
what's-his-name didn't look so bad on it
um Bernie because he is like I mean he
treated it like any normal person what
do they like your this guy's a [ __ ]
idiot
if it was trying to be like sensitive it
was really sweet actually but the
Republican guys at the end were just
like that guy what's his name the
[ __ ] guy who was like the the brunt
of it I don't know but he was like Joe
Walsh right he was just like he was just
like oh he got me like no you said dude
you said we should arm three-year-olds
use
said kinder Grenadiers or whatever the
[ __ ] it was turned kindergartners into
kindergarten as where the [ __ ] he said
but like you said that and then he was
like oh now he got me
no you said that though and and a lot of
people are like well if you saw that if
you were there though when you got
tricked you wouldn't know how you
reacted no I don't [ __ ] buy that I
get our brains are only our brains and
our brains are only what happened to us
and the only thing we are are who our
brains and what has happened to our
brains but still no no there is no
[ __ ] way any person who is a real
person who isn't a piece of [ __ ] would
not say that or there would say that any
person who is not a piece of [ __ ] would
say that you know I'm trying to [ __ ]
say but that's just like to give
kindergarteners guns dude and to read
from a teleprompter it doesn't matter
you bi I would turn around and say you
want me to say this [ __ ] [ __ ] are you
out of your mind these guys and you know
I was talking to somebody and they were
like yeah but bro they you know they're
on there they're there doing these
interviews all day they're not thinking
no [ __ ] that it doesn't matter no it
doesn't matter even more so to my point
if you're doing all of those all day
long you have to be on your vigilance
even more so dude that's crazy what they
were doing and here's the other thing
too that was the most eye-opening
jaw-dropping [ __ ] about our country in
this time in the in the what's happening
to this world and in our country
specifically that was the most
jaw-dropping
and eye-opening thing that has happened
I think I think period the most alarming
thing when it comes to gun control and
nothing's gonna change dude nothing will
change because the people who want the
guns out there are going to look at that
and be like oh yeah but he [ __ ]
tricked him you know
nothing's gonna change nothing's gonna
change and I was talking to my mom about
this and I was like it sucks cuz
nothing's gonna change and she's like
yeah but you still have to try and she I
guess she's right that was like yeah I
guess that's a good point because it's
like you can't just be like all right
nothing's gonna change [ __ ] it because
you still have to try it's like those
movies is like where they're at the end
like almost at the end we're like but we
still have to try and it's like but
what's the point and it's like because
it's who we are I guess that's true
you know the whole dying for a cause
thing or whatever you know I guess you
have to [ __ ] to have people like that
we don't all need to be like that but
like the really important people have to
be like that um is that how that movie
was last samurai womp far as bringing up
Last Samurai Tom Cruise you know Tom
Cruise you know anyway um yeah we should
do Twitter questions right let's do a
question pull him up pull him up I
didn't watch the ending of Sopranos this
person's asking me I only saw like the
first four seasons like an idiot I'm
gonna watch it slap it's time to kind of
took it out to wind under your sail took
the wind out of yourself
crystal Kade Holland deck sir Russian
Holland yet sounds like you've had a
handful of hecklers at your show from
time to time
I mean it's about tracking at the end of
the sentence Eddie need during an
attempt to shoot a special Oh
no but the worst is well the worst I
think the worst well I can't say the
worst is this what the worst is but like
the Woo's like dude shut up it's not
about you man whoo that [ __ ] just
stepping on the [ __ ] punchlines and
the joke
it's so [ __ ] annoying
whooing at a comedy show I'm not the
[ __ ] Diamondbacks dude go woo at a
[ __ ] ballgame
it's not about you dude you're ruining
the show for other people man god that's
so annoying I used to date a girl that
hated sounds she would just be like I
get so annoyed when [ __ ] was and I never
got it until I [ __ ] lose at a comedy
show man that's the war in the beginning
it's fine
whoo you come out yeah but dude I'm not
[ __ ] INXS I'm not [ __ ] Duran Duran
dude laughing don't laugh that's it this
[ __ ] Ryan DiGregorio first of all that
last name at did Gregorio he spelled it
Oreo though like the cookie what do you
think about people who say it's their
Jordan year when they turned 23 I didn't
know people do that but that's that's
really [ __ ] stupid that's some [ __ ]
whoo that's a guy who double fists at a
party who says that and goes like this
classic dude classic at things that
aren't classic that's so awful that's
that's so awful you know rape is so
awful but that's bad
what that's it so I don't know we could
wrap this up though that was good that
was a fun one
so we got an listen to listen before is
well first of all no let me say this
before we wrap up we have a new shirt
coming to the store in the next couple
days all right
new merch merchandise and we've got the
shirt coming and it's a [ __ ] hot one
dude it's for follow-the-leader and it's
[ __ ] hot and I want to wear it but
it's got me on it so I'm not sure if I'm
gonna wear it but I like
a lot it's a [ __ ] dog shirt and I'm
gonna bring him on tour too and have
people sell them so be on the lookout
for that
follow the leader tour buy tickets chris
d'elia comm Wichita Kansas Kansas City
Lincoln Reno Nevada Las Vegas Ottawa
Ontario London Ontario Buffalo New York
Burlington Vermont Philadelphia these
are the LAT these are the next few ones
Philadelphia Washington DC New York
Montclair New Jersey and then we got
Oregon and [ __ ] like that but anyway
Houston this weekend see me in Houston
this weekend get hot with me babies
subscribe to the YouTube channel
download the Christa Lea app for iOS or
Android now square cash check out the
new boost rewards program get the cash
app enter rewards code congrats get $5
get and give $5 - times up get it for
iOS or Android now write and review the
show please will be really helpful when
you do that on on the all wherever you
listen to it on the audio like iTunes
would be great it helps us out and it
gets us one step closer to that [ __ ]
illustrious lab log-cabin video episodes
go up Tuesdays are Wednesdays watch my
specials share them with a friend and
I'm gonna be on I think I'm on the
premiere episode I'm on a bunch of the
episodes of this alone together TV show
second season it premieres August 1st I
think I'm on the first one - anyway
thanks guys and remember to set it and
forget it
[Music]